what's up guys I'm Greg I am John we're
gonna talk about Godzilla king of the
monsters been really looking forward to
this flick after all those trailers to
make this blunt you have to check this
out on for DX when this movie was done
we saw said there is so much for DX this
is the 40 exes to film I most you could
experience I mean like I live through
that disaster this movie has so much
like fight scenes and battle sequences
and different weather locations and
every time they change it up or do they
utilize it with the strobe lights the
smoke effect with snow the fire effects
the heating effect like the water the
way they time not just the timing of the
chairs but those specific movements of
how the chairs work we're so calculating
throughout this film it was a non-stop
ride and when the bites are going on you
feel like you're a part of it actually
enhances the emotional intensity of the
fight sequences so yes thank you guys
for bringing us through there because
Wow for DX to the extreme there on to
the actual review of Godzilla king of
the monsters we've seen these trailers
it looked beautiful it looked epic the
basic plotline is I'm gonna refer them
by their actor names Kyle Chandler has
been brought in by monarch because his
ex-wife Vera Farmiga their daughter
Millie Bob around having kidnapped by
eco-terrorist played by Tywin Lannister
these eco-terrorists they basically want
to unleash all the titans out of five
years have gone by they know where a lot
of titans are located they want to
unleash them you know global warming
humans suck the reason well you know how
those plot lines go in movies and
weirdly enough as much as I hate that
trope just being beat to death in films
it actually works in this movie like the
idea the concept of it does that mean
it's always logical and reproach not
necessarily but it makes sense to
include it Godzilla's always had an
ecological bent at least somewhere for
this movie I felt it to be appropriate
inclusion backed by a powerful
PowerPoint presentation several times in
this movie for a most exposition
when a character has a computer here you
go I prepped all this I don't have open
google chrome tabs I have a whole slide
ready for you to get what are the main
things you show up for in this film the
human care the paintings you show Rama
movie are the monster battle is the
epicness and then coming off of the 2014
Godzilla which apparently has people
divided I wasn't fully aware of this
until recent talk of this specific
installment but apparently a lot of
people weren't on board with the fact
that Godzilla only shows up for three
and a half minutes in the first one yeah
and they very much took that criticism
studio notes are very apparent here
there is monster mayhem a lot in this
movie and you definitely you definitely
get more Godzilla in here off of that
alone for a theater experience I don't
know so much about you know if this was
like a Netflix movie or something like
oh you got to check this out sure it
would still be plenty to appreciate but
off of a theater experience I'm gonna
tell you Rock the bat I'm recommending
this movie because I'm gonna go again as
the visual palette in here is so
beautiful like they make up a bunch of
great excuses to go to different parts
of the world and get different types of
weather conditions to see Godzilla and
Ghidorah fight in the snow and then the
heat of Mexico and lava the fight scenes
in here are so epic and I love the
confidence in the visuals where you get
so many awesome close-ups and so many
shots it's just like paintings and
portraits in here for the visual
aesthetic alone and for the fact that
they fully deliver on this monster
mayhem for a theater experience
hell yeah a theater experience yeah
absolutely go check this out yeah I mean
the big-screen spectacle and the kaiju
are really the stars of this movie and
yeah they definitely took that criticism
to heart yeah I mean it has a lot of the
things that dog a lot of other Godzilla
installments but especially if you're
down for the spectacle and if you are a
die-hard Godzilla fan definitely the
movie theater the biggest screen
possible the most deluxe presentation
you can find is the way to enjoy this
because I mean it's the epitome of a
summer blockbuster and if there's
anything that in arguably nails it's the
monster fight yeah I always need to be
as big as possible and the music in here
is also wonderful
like RiRi I loved loved listening to
that music in this film an awesome sound
design - I didn't know that like the
embargo had lifted when we were watching
the movie so I didn't know what anyone
thought of this movie I know I saw some
Tomatoes yes I didn't I had no idea what
people thought of this movie my initial
opinion which seems to me held true
after breezing through some capsules is
like it's the most I've done so far this
is what I thought when I was watching it
because there were enough that I picked
up on of like some Godzilla lore and and
some Easter eggs and stuff is if you're
a hardcore Godzilla fan like if you're a
fan of the like just the franchise in
general you're probably gonna love this
movie if you're not someone who's
necessarily a big fan of that it was
more just like a film enthusiast and
really loved and appreciated the
execution of the 2014 Godzilla this will
make you appreciate that movie yeah you
probably won't like this movie yeah
the human characters in here it's not a
good script or at least it's not a good
edit from a four-hour movie initially
it's one of the terrible script or it's
a really edited down movie yeah it feels
like somebody made like a military
thriller drama thing and then really cut
it down to its main plot points and then
shoved a bunch of monster action where
all the scenes used to be and that's
kind of how the humans story and this
plays out which isn't out of place
necessarily for a Godzilla film you
shouldn't just give a pass because we
don't expect a good character work in
good human story they aren't very good
in this movie they're mostly saved by
the actors who are all committed like a
thousand percent to the heavy drama so
there's a point where you're like
there's all going for the heavy other
than Bradley Whitford who just seems to
want to have a fun time everyone else in
this movie throughout goes for the heavy
yes and move in for a script that's not
good
I feel like it could have weirdly used
some Michael Dougherty touches to it
some more of that fun that could have
made up for a lot of the human
interaction in human drama because
honestly most of the focus is on the
humans so it's hard not to think and
criticize that element old Godzilla
movies you can say that of too and that
kind of makes this land for me a mom
the mid-range of all the films just
because it doesn't make a thin story and
thin characters in a way where it knows
what it's doing and has fun with that
fact the problem for me too is it's kind
of a boilerplate human story we've seen
these circumstances and half this
dialogue a thousand times and a thousand
other of this kind of movie so I kind of
just wish they had gotten more original
with what kind of human story they
wanted to try and shove into this
because it's always gonna be kind of
problematic to do we're always gonna
want to see the monsters fight and we're
always gonna need to put that around
some sort of story but yeah I wish
Michael Dougherty have been able to put
a stylistic stamp of some kind on this
or a personality on it because the pace
and the tone overall mostly just felt
like cacophony I didn't really have a
dynamic much you never mean the first
half of this movie I actually really
enjoyed there's a couple of scenes I
could think of that truly provided some
real suspense for me real tension even
though the characters are all arc types
that we've seen before I was on board
for the characters in the first half of
this movie the basic set up of Kyle
Chandler and his weird you know looking
at wolves experiments since he's doing
and Avera for megamillion their dynamics
everything about them I was on board for
a little bit past the halfway point when
they get to like Mexico or Rodin is
introduced as you see in the trailers it
was after that when everything just
starts just so much plots so convoluted
so much of so much of so much coming in
and a lot of convenient stuff and Kyle
Chandler just seems to know everything
about everything in this movie like
every actor in this movie does a pretty
good job it's just the writing of them
and I think the most disappointing part
of it is in terms of marketing is Millie
Bobby Brown is barely a character in
this she's just pretty much a daughter
it's not just that the human story is
lackluster there were times where it
would have me distracted or asking
questions all of a sudden about what's
possible in this world that I shouldn't
really be thinking about in this movie I
thought the movie was at its best when
it was taking its time and being visual
because there are a couple moments that
really bother to change the tone have
some beautiful choral music and some
different color palettes especially when
like Mothra is on screen or there's
another sequence involved in Godzilla I
won't get into too much detail and Ken
Watanabe as well like that I thought was
a gorgeous sequence that really pulled
me in
captivated me and I spent the rest of
the movie wondering kind of why more of
it didn't give me that feeling and even
though you get more Godzilla in here
technically to meet only felt like you
got like 15 more minutes
really really you got so much more
Godzilla in here my one complaint about
the handling of Godzilla is I never felt
like he had a scene that was his the
first movie he doesn't just have moments
in the first movie that final fight
that's his seen Godzilla or even in the
big finale fight of this movie there's
so much cutting around to other stuff
and so many other things going on I
can't go into spoilers of stuff I just
never felt like Godzilla had his scene I
felt like he always had moments even in
the finale like that's his moment these
are the moments but not the Godzilla
scene you know yeah this five minutes
yeah like a lot of the other monsters
get that and Godzilla for a lot of the
movie is sort of like ah looks like
you're having a rough time with these
guys just get in there and do it buddy
but you know God feels so cool in it
movies still a lot of fun still plenty
to be had at what you mainly care to
show up for it works
jam-packed plot in the last half
especially oh yeah but hey that's not
what you're there for yeah you're there
for awesomeness right yeah go to whine
you're gonna get you might just have to
sit through some people talking in the
middle did you see Godzilla king of the
monsters who do you want to see Godzilla
worse
what's crossover do you want it's not
King Kong which is movie really wanted
me to be reassured of every 15 minutes
that Kong is gonna be in the next movie
you guys can subscribe to the reject
nation click that notification bell if
you liked this video hit the like button
and last but not least patient add a
shout out to a man named Tyler hey Tyler
this movie is your kind of movie trust
me dude you don't care about nuance you
don't care about heavy
characterization emotional arcs you care
primarily about having a
balls-to-the-wall time because that's
you every day flapping your balls all
over your apartment walls every time
we've done a Google hangout with you
that's the usually the intro that we get
you buddy and this movie certainly
defines that oh yeah your balls on my
walls walls being my face as a metaphor
if these walls could talk they would be
my face